this thing that i'm always invading
about about
ego is i think very true
we are um
so similar that any one of us could
stand in for any of the other of us
so this thing we spend our entire life
creating called
my unique personality is
a yuppie indulgence indulgence just like
the bmw and the picasso print and all
the rest of it
nobody is really special intelligence
is special when compared to stupidity
but no one holds the patent on
intelligence
and i i don't believe that intelligence
is something that you're born
with intelligence is something that you
learn
uh everybody starts out stupid
and it's just some people uh remain
that way because of the failure to
inculcate
curiosity curiosity
is the great virtue and the reason i'm
into psychedelics to the degree that i
am is because i'm interested
in the world and it's taken me
in many many directions from tropical
butterflies
to rocket building to paleontology
to surrealism to tantra
to psychedelics and the reason i'm not
giving a lecture somewhere in the world
today on butterflies or tantra
is because psychedelics are more
interesting
than those things each thing is a step
to something else
you know when you talk to shamans
psychedelic or otherwise there's a lot
of emphasis on what they call
the way of the ancestors and this sound
this is a good new age
phrase and it sort of has a vaguely
furry and friendly sound to it
but what is the way of the ancestors
really
to my mind the way to think about
yourself
is that you are the front end
of a genetic shock
moving through the genetic environment
and if as i sit and talk to you
i scratch my head and let's assume
i am uh pissed free for a moment
then this gesture is
part of the way of my ancestors you know
i had a grandfather a great grandfather
a second cousin who did this
everything about you is inherited
nothing about you is uniquely yours
unless you have some lethal mutation
that has sprung into being
in your lifetime and is probably going
to plant you
but everything serviceable about you
is inherited from the past
so not only are we not different from
each other but we are not different
greatly from the people who preceded us
and on a scale of 10
000 years the differences are are
minuscule to non-existent
so uh part of the political awareness
that comes out of psychedelics
is the taking it is the defocusing of
the sense of
self strangely enough and
people this is a tricky message to put
out because people
say well are you saying then
that we should be perfectly comfortable
in some kind of human anthill
is this a kind of crypto fascist
idea i don't think so
it is not true that the finest
achievement of western civilization
is the democratically empowered
individual ego that is not the finest
flower of our
civilization the finest flower of our
civilization to my mind
is the ideal of charity
community and a generalized sense of
human dignity
that does is often um somewhat
limited in its expression in other
societies
i mean when pachau went to his tomb if
you read
the description in the forest of kings
at the end of a very elaborate ceremony
and
almost as an afterthought his
uh his uh inheritor
uh sacrifices
four captives before he climbs back up
the stairs and it's almost like
oh my god we've had this two hour
ceremony i've been wearing this jade
pectoral i'm
sweating like a pig now i have to kill
four people before i can
take a shower and change clothes and
then he does it
this is not a society where the
generalized
values of human worth and community
were very highly expressed
okay so that's one point then this other
point
which is uh more my
special i mean i feel uncomfortable
preaching a dogma
of moral awareness because i'm perfectly
aware that
my behavior could not survive
any kind of thorough scrutiny at
all and i revel in it and seek not to
change i figure warning people is all
you have to do
you don't have to reform your character
if i listen to you what you're saying is
pure
oh good i'm glad there's some
traditional
backing but the other point that i
wanted to make and this is
my personal opinion but
held fiercely is
that the real if we say that
psychedelics expand consciousness then
we mean something more than just that
you're aware of
the gradients of color or the subtleties
at dinner in conversation what what
expansion of consciousness means in a
historical framework
is ideas
ideas civilization
and uncivilization have all been built
out of ideas urbanism
monotheism the sum of the square of the
hypotenuse equals the sum of the square
of the other two sides the keyed arch
the ratchet the pulley ideas
and again i would challenge you as we
look
at the 20th century
where are the ideas that the psychedelic
community
can lay clear claim to
was einstein loaded was marked
was freud were the people who
fractionated dna the first time
were the people who went to the moon
were the people who propounded
um fascism you know where
are the ideas uh we cannot
move and i think i said this in one of
my other lectures we cannot move any
faster
than the language that we evolve
and we cannot move into the future any
faster than the ideas
that we generate and right now
in the aftermath of the collapse of
marxism
no critique is being carried
out of the dominant
ideology that rules the planet which is
marketing economics capitalism
consumerism there is no coherent
critique being brought forth against
these things
now we have a fragmented opposition
to the to the reigning paradigm of the
marketplace
and the opposition names itself various
ways
there's feminism
there's anti-racism
there is ecological consciousness
uh and there is psychedelic
awareness to my mind one of the great
failures in the political dialogue at
the end of the
century is that these groups of people
have not
made common cause why is it so hard to
explain to a feminist
why they should be an ecologist
why is it so hard to claim to explain to
both of those parties why they should
take
psychedelics the opposition
to the reigning paradigm of market
economy and product
fetishism is woefully fragmented
you know what does gay rights have to do
with racism what does that have to do
with the destruction of
the rain forest and what does that have
to do
with the manufacture of unnecessary
products with
toxic byproducts well the answer is
everything everything because what we're
talking about here is the quality of the
human experience of
the living world and you know john dunn
said every man's death diminishes me
every person's suffering diminishes
your happiness i personally
have found it in the last several years
and i don't know whether it's because of
my personal circumstance or
or the larger picture but it becomes
harder and harder to take
very large doses of psychedelics because
there's a part of the trip which i call
the world
news and the world news
is hard to put up with and the
visions the images of
the forced rape concentration camps in
serbia the distended bellies of the
children of somalia
and then intercut with the vast and
mindless
wealth of the high-tech industrial
democracies it's uh it's a picture
of human uh
self-hatred and mismanagement
and the consequences are global
every man's death every person's
suffering
diminishes the quality of human
experience generally
how much misery can there be in the
world
before no one can take psychedelics
because it simply inducts you into
an awareness two horrible to contemplate
well i don't have the answer to this but
i think
that these other groups of people the
people who are disturbed by
racism and sexism and environmental
destruction
what we can bring to this dialogue
is more than a persuasive
argument because if persuasive arguments
could carry the day
then the sermon on the mount would have
marked the turning point
or you know gandhi or somebody else
what we bring is an actual
pharmacological intervention
into the unconscious side of the human
experience i think the reason shamanism
endured for half a million years without
generating profane history
is because it created a sense of
self-worth
in people that caused them to
not need to build enormous
earthworks or enslave other people
or even carve jade and wood
because the inner worth was felt to be
sufficient we are the most individually
impoverished people the world has ever
known
all our self-worth comes through social
status
ownership of things the size of our bank
account
so forth and so on so i think we need to
demand of ourselves a greater
political awareness and a greater
willingness
and i'm not faulting this group because
i think we're at the cutting edge here
but a greater willingness to stand up
and be counted uh the dominator paradigm
has us locked into where we are pleading
for our right to take psychedelics
this is and when we say to ourselves
in some of our conversations that the
holy grail would arrive if they would
allow us to take psychedelics
this is a cockamamie notion they should
be pleading for
an exemption from the obligation
to take psychedelics and be connected
into the guy in
mind tim leary
said an amazing thing years ago or at
least i
say he said it once i tried to give him
credit for it and he denied he'd ever
said it
but whoever said it was brilliant they
said
lsd is a psychoactive compound
which occasionally causes psychotic
behavior
in people who have not taken it
[Music]
this is truth for sure and we are
surrounded by people who exhibit all
kinds of psychotic
behaviors because
they have an inner conviction that they
are
mad and they're right
this is what the fear of psychedelics is
rooted in i think
is the people who are truly embedded in
dominator values
say i i wouldn't touch that stuff
you know i don't want to explore my
psyche i don't want to know who i really
am i don't want to connect up to our
historical legacy
or the state of the earth damn right
they don't because they understand that
it would be almost more painful than
could be born and to a degree we are
affected with this same thing one thing
about
psychedelics is that they make you feel
the situation
well but who could feel the situation
and not be blind you know if
if everybody on earth could suddenly tap
into the way things feel things feel
terrible epidemic diseases great wealth
in the presence of great poverty
the roaring extinction of species
the endless mills of propaganda
the situation doesn't feel very good and
so as consciousness
expands the news is not all
good news i think there's an inner core
of humanness that is still uncorrected
but a thousand five thousand years of
practicing
dominator style social systems and
ideologies
has left us with very little room to
maneuver
[Music]
you